الى اوكرانيا في اول تصريح رسميه من نوهيه
قال القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال فاليري زولوجي انه من
الممكنه قتال القوات الروسيه على اراضيها
باستخدام الاسلحه الاوكرانيه بقدر ما هو
ضروري وفق تعبيره واشار زلوجني خلال حديثا
لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الى ان الامر متروك
لتقدير قواته في كيفيه مواجهه القوات
الروسيه واضاف قائد الجيش الاوكراني ان
شركاء بلاده يخشون استخدام اسلحتهم لتوجيه
ضربات اوكرانيه داخل روسيا يشار الى ان
كييف لا تعترف رسميا بانها تنفذ عمليات
عسكريه داخل الاراضي الروسيه
في الاثناء نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
مسؤولين امريكيين او مسؤولين ان اوكرانيا
خسرت ما يصل الى 20% من اسلحتها في
الاسبوعين الاولين من هجومها المضاد وقال
المسؤولون للصحيفه ان خسائر الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد تراجعت بدايه من
الاسبوع الثالث بعد تباطؤ الى هجمات
الاوكرانيه واضافوا ان اوكرانيا ركزت على
اضعاف القوات الروسيه بالمدفعيه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى وانها غيرت
تكتيكاتها
في روسيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استدعاء 147 الف مجندا للخدمه العسكريه في
الجيش بعد اكتمال عمليات التجنيد في ربيع
العام الجاري يذكر ان مرسومه تجنيد
العسكريه الالزاميه صدر نهايه تمارس اذار
الماضي اما ارسال المجندين فبدا في
العشرين من ابريل واكتمل اليوم
من بيروت الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
عميد الياس مرحبا بك معنا قتال حسب
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه قتال قوات
الروسيه ممكن على اراضيها هل هو حقيقه
ممكن وهل من جدوى عسكريه لذلك
سلمى عندما يعني نسمع هذا التصريح يجب ان
ننظر الى الامكانيات هل الامكانيات تسمح
بالقتال داخل الاراضي الروسيه واذا كانت
تسمح ما هي هذه الوسائل هل هي المسيرات هل
هي الصواريخ البعيده المدى هذه امور صعبه
اليوم حاليا هل هي عبر من هم الميليشيات
التي يتمردت على
الرئيس بوتين انا اعتقد اليوم هذا الامر
هو يعني تصريح في الهواء ولكن الفعل
الاساسي هو على الجبهه داخل اوكرانيا التي
تمتد 900 كم
عميد الياس صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تحدثت بان
قوات الاوكرانيه خسرت 20% من اسلحتها في
الاسبوعين الاولين فقط من هجومها المضاد
برايك ما هي العوامل التي ادت الى مثل هذا
هذه الخساره وهل هو ما دفعها الى مثل هذه
التصريحات مثلا
سلمى عشرين بالمئه هي نسبه عاليه من عدد
محدود لا يمكن لاوكرانيا تعويضه ان كان في
العتاد او في العديد ولا يجب ان ننسى ان
هذا العتاد هو جديد والتدريب الاوكراني
على هذا العتاد هو شيء جديد ايضا وليس
لديهم خبره في الامور الهجوميه الخسائر
ادت كانت بسبب الانتقال من وضع الدفاع الى
وضع الهجوم بحيث كان للقوات الروسيه فتره
طويله لتحصين الجبهه على 800 كيلو متر
وبعمق داخل الاراضي او الخط الدفاعي بعمق
30 كيلومتر وهذا امر صعب جدا والخطوره
دائما سلمى ان لا تصل القوات الاوكرانيه
الى نقطه الذروه او ما يسمى بالكالمينيشن
وهذا حصل مع القوات الروسيه في سفر
دونيتسك
حيث وصلت الى المدى الاقصى لها بعدها سلمى
لم نعد نرى باستثناء بخموت حيث قاتلت
عمليات هجومه يا روسيه
وهنا
غيرت بعد هذا الفشل في الاسبوعين والخساره
20 بيئه من قواتها غيرت اوكرانيا
تكتيكاتها واعتمدت على الحاق ضربات
بالقوات الروسيه عن طريق المدفعيه وايضا
صواريخ بعيده المدى هل هذا التكتيك هو
تكتيك يتبع عسكريا في مثل هذه الحالات
سلمى دائما عند المشكله التقنيه هناك حلول
تكتيكيه في كيفيه الاستعمال هي لم تغير
نتذكر ما حصل في خرسون اتبعت نفس التكتيك
ونفس الوسيله حرمت الجيش الروسي المتواجد
في مدينه خرسان من خطوط المواصلات فانسحب
ولكن الوسيله لم تكن موجوده اليوم لدينا
الهايمرز 80 كم
250 وقد ياتي الاسكالب الفرنسي 300 كيلو
متر او الصاروخ الامريكي اتى كامز 300 كلم
بالاضافه الى المدفعيه العاديه مع
المسيرات الهدف منها دائما هو استراتيجيه
حرمان الجيش الروسي الذي يستهلك الكثير من
الذخيره والمؤن والوقود من هذه الامور
اللوجستيه بحيث يصعب عليه خوض المعركه او
الدفاع
اليوم روسيا اعلنت او وزاره الدفاع اعلنت
استدعاء قرابه 150 الفا مجند ممن تم
تجنيدهم الزاميا ضمن عمليه التجنيد الجزئي
التي جرت في بدايه العام اين برايك سيوضع
وما هي حجم الفعاليه لمثل هذه الاعداد
الجديده في المعركه
سلمى هذه هؤلاء المجندون الجدد حسب
القانون الروسي لا يمكن استعمالهم في
الخارج خارج روسيه في الحرب ولكن بعد ان
ضم الرئيس بوتين الاربعه اقاليم اعتبرت
هذه الارض وكانها ارض روسيه يمكن
استعمالهم لتغطيه اماكن دفاعيه على طول
الجبهه وتحرير القوى الاساسيه النخبه
للحرب للهجوم والهجوم المضاد ولكن يبقى
هذه الوحدات هي وحدات بسيطه ليس لدي خبره
تدريب بسيط هي عرضه للمزيد من الخسائر
اعمده الياسه هلا اللجوم المضاد لا زال
قائما من وجهه نظرك
هو قائم ولكن ببطء لا نزال في المرحله جس
النبض واعتقد اليوم يجب تغيير
الاستراتيجيه بشكل كامل المكان الوحيد
الذي يتم الهجوم فيه هو في مخموت لماذا
لانه في هذه الجبهه ليست كما جبهه الجنوب
هناك الدفاعات على مسافه 300 ثلاثين
كيلومتر هذه الجبهه هي كانت محضره هي
استمرار لما فعله فاغنر واليوم هناك
الهجوم العكسي وهذا امر قد يتم تحقيق شيء
منه ولكن الهجوم الاوكراني متعثر وبطيء
شكرا جزيلا لكم بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه الياس حنا شكرا على
المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]